and the reports and so on
no problems with that before we go to
start
well oh it is half past now
so yeah ready are you okay for me to
start sonia
yes
yes that's fine thank you
all right good evening everybody welcome
to
the development committee of rochefort
district council
on the 10th of december 2020
our first item is apologies for absence
and they're on on there are number two
no substitute members obviously
non-members attending
i've seen councillor mr hoy councilman
scudding
councillor wilkinson i don't think i've
missed anyone thank you um
minutes of the meeting held on the 19th
of november
2020 are you happy for those to be
signed
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting
just a visual show of hands or a call
out will do
okay thank you yes
um item five to receive declarations of
interest i will do one first
regarding item number nine the
for openness and transparency the
applicant
is known to the council so there is no
further need for anyone to disclose
any other personal interests with regard
to that one
um are there any other interests to be
declared
give myself a moment to look around the
screen
that's good okay thank you
our next item is item number six
item we've seen before land to the rear
of
eight st john's road great wakering
and mr strengths is going to be
presenting for us this evening
mike thank you thank you chairman this
application is
to a backland site with two vacant
buildings on the western side of st
john's road the current application for
the demolition of those buildings
and to the construction of two new
buildings to provide four one-bedroom
flats
was deferred at the meeting of the 19th
of november
and that was in order that officers
could seek legal advice on the position
in relation to members continued
concerns at the lack of visitor
parking in the current scheme members
will recall that an earlier scheme for
the conversion of the existing building
to five one-bedroom flats was refused
permission because of the inadequate
immunity space
and the lack of visitor parking
on the appeal the inspector considered
that the two visitor spaces required for
that scheme
uh could generally be met from on-street
parking but the inspector agreed with
members that the immunity space
shortfall
could not be accepted and dismissed the
appeal for just that reason
now the current scheme is for one less
flat
and resolves the amenity space issue
because what was
a shortfall of 1945
units becomes a surplus of six square
meters even though it's the same area
for the four that are proposed so
without alteration to the buildings much
the garden area
now complies um and because it's
four flats then they only require four
parking spaces plus one visitor space
which isn't provided in this scheme
and at the last meeting members were
still concerned about that lack
of visitor parking
but remember in mind that the inspector
found that
two spaces for visitors was considered
by him generally acceptable and
available within the street
so obviously having half that
requirement down to one
then logically it's even more acceptable
now
officers have now received the advice
from counsel which
is set out in the update to the front of
the officer report
but put in summary
the advice concludes that a decision to
refuse planning permission on the
grounds of a shortfall in parking
would not be defensible unless
new and materially different
circumstances become evident
since the previous decision in simple
terms chairman
the advice is that there would need to
be demonstrated new evidence to the
unacceptability of the lack of visitor
parking
before members now to such an extent
that the previous inspector would have
come to a different conclusion
had it before had it been before him in
considering the appeal
officers are not aware of any
significant changes in circumstances
since the consideration and appeal and
given that the problem
is effectively now halved by requiring
only one space whereas the inspector
found
that the need for two was still
acceptable the burden
of finding that evidence is now much
heavier to prove
so whilst members may disagree with the
inspectors findings
given the degree of parking stress set
out by residents in the reply to
notifications on
on the application the inspector's
decision is nevertheless a material
consideration that now carries
significant weight
in the balance of considerations that we
weigh up as
planning authority furthermore the
advice of council does not favor
refusing the application
in the circumstances so that now adds
extra advice over and above what we
understand so far
the recommendation chairman is there for
approval subject to the conditions set
out in the report and the amendment that
you were assumed to condition nine
proposed by officers
to require obscure glazing to both side
windows that's the north and south ends
um to the building on plot one on the
eastern
boundary of the site thank you general
thank you
would you mind just unsharing the screen
so that uh
i've got clear vision of uh
what's been indicated please thank you
i i don't see any non-members
indicating at this point members given
the
uh the the fact that we took this me
this
item some detail
last time and that we have had
the information
requested i feel on this occasion
i need to directly move the approval
from the chair
at this point and now
take first counsellor mrs shaw
thank you chairman i was going to say
the same as we've discussed this at
length
in two other meetings and we've had
um the site of the plans on both
meetings uh and
amended can we go straight to a vote
please on this
thank you
noted councillor stanley
thank you chairman um i've got to bring
up
another issue which is separate from
this issue that we are talking that you
have just spoken
in as much as um
could i ask the officer
mr strengths exactly what our parking
standards
are and good design practice please
right uh mr strengths would you care to
answer that
one
thank you chairman i'll assume that it's
good design of parking standards as
opposed to
good design overall the the standard for
flats is one car parking space for every
one bedroomed
flat and two car parking spaces
if the flat has two bedrooms or more but
there's a requirement for visitor
spaces of a quarter of a space per flat
so in the previous scheme uh it required
two spaces because effectively
applying the standard it required one
and a quarter spaces you can't have a
quarter of a space so it rounds up
to the next space making it two this
application because it's now
four four flats
it requires one visitor space and one
car parking space for each of the
flats proposed now the preferred bay
size that we
go for is 2.9 uh
meters wide by 5.5 meters
in depth um
that's i think the answer i i think that
members were seeking tumor
thank you thank you chairman and thank
you
my strengths right members um
i know i've got the answer but i i
haven't made my point
um could i ask then what is the minimum
size of parking area that
is required by the council please
please mr strangs thank you chairman
the minimum size is 2.5 by five meters
in depth
could could event tell me how two people
from a four door
car can get out of a car
both sides in 2.5 meters i'll i'll
i'll take that that answer the planning
application
doesn't require an answer like like that
we're looking to explore new and
substantial issues that have not been
previously explored within this
application um
i'm now going to move on to councillor
hookway please
thank you chairman um can i ask
mr shranks as to whether essex fire and
rescue
um made any comment in relation to
accessibility and
the issues of safety uh and
accessibility to
uh the the site and the road
of saint john's in relation to uh issues
would you like to make any points please
thank you chairman it's just that i find
it disappointing
that the inspector doesn't look at our
standard of 2.9 meters
and looks at the essex county council
design guide
which 2.6 meters which i think it is
above 2.5
we try and get the best for our
residents and to be overruled like this
is he's
calling calling to said at least thank
you councillor wilson
thank you chairman um i seem to recall i
can't remember exactly where it was
but um if the um
parking space is against a hard boundary
so a wall for example
there has to be a i think it was an
extra meter or something
could mr strengths confirm that please
are there any other there's no other
members indicating at the moment if i
could ask you mr strengths just to
answer
those two questions um on
on consultation with fire and
uh against a hard hard-worn place
thank you chairman um they're not aware
that there was a direct consultation
with essex and fire rescue
you have to bear in mind that the
matters of fire protection is dealt with
under the building rigs
now there's two ways of doing that the
fire tender i think can get down an
access way that's three meters wide
um and a 40 meter distance or 45 meters
distance i think for hoses but if that's
not possible they
then do it the other way with with
sprinklers or rising mains so
it's rare for us to to get involved with
access
for poor fire engines where a parking
space is hard against
some obstruction i could take the point
about the need for overhang particularly
as the vehicles
uh move but i'm not aware of any of any
standard chairman i mean usually when we
see this
um in landscaping the developers
uh account for that but i'm not other
than the garage
internal width which is uh um 2.9
um sorry three meters wide which would
give you an extra point one of a meter
um i'm not aware of any standard where
it's against say fences or walls
thank you members we have explored this
application in great detail we've taken
the specific advice
we need to come to a decision on this
one
i believe that you have had all the
necessary memories
yeah i'm talking please
please don't interrupt i'd like to raise
a point of order
if you'd let me finish please thank you
we have we have received all of the
information
that that's been requested and we have
all of the necessary information i
believe
to come to a decision we have had
independent advice that it would be
considered
unreasonable to object to this
application and we have had clear advice
from our officers so we are about to go
to a vote
councillor hook where you indicated on a
point of order
thank you yes chairman um mr strengths
um
um gave us some information related to
uh a question that i asked
um i would have thought it might be
appropriate to ask if there was
something i needed to uh
respond to what he put forward no
i don't i don't believe that it is
necessary to further
establish establish uh continue the
debate i believe
he has provided an indication that an
area has um haven't we haven't received
a report from uh
some expert in in that could could be
material to this uh particular
application
so we could actually say that a report
from essex
fire um could uh have a
be additional information that is
wasn't put before the inspector i am
taking the judgment
that on planning grounds we have
sufficient
information to make a decision
the opportunity to raise all the various
significant issues was offered last time
the specific
items required that were requested
have been provided i think it is
appropriate that we now go
to a vote on this
so members
the mosha they
recommendation for approval is printed
on
page 6.2 there are 12 points
there's that little amendment that
officers mentioned
with regard to obscure blazing
there are no hands indicating at present
motion being seconded i didn't see it
here any one second
it's been moved from the chair counselor
um so can i ask if you wish to have a
recorded vote
could you please indicate
sort of a point of order chairman i
believe even if it's moved from a chair
it still needs to be seconded as a
motion
i will second that chair look a
councillor sure
okay we've had an indication of
past the threshold so we'll now move to
a
recorded vote if you wouldn't mind
taking your hands down
this will be on the call
so they're in favor
of the motion for approval counselor
butcher
um councillor smith yeah sorry
um for the recorded vote we we need we
need members to indicate that they're
voting for
against or abstaining because it will be
a recorded vote
so it's those members who are voting for
initially
so council butcher
oh thank you
cancer fd
so i'm not sure what quite what we're
voting for here you're voting
you're voting if you're in favor of the
motion for approval it's printed on 6.2
and the 12 points
so we say yes no or abstain or
something that that yes that's that's
right
sorry on a point of order um legal
officer has stated that it is possible
not to vote as well
there are four things you can do you can
vote for against
abstain or not vote can i can i please
um can i please uh
clarify that uh not when
a fifth of members present have voted
for recorded vote
when when when a fifth members uh
president have asked for a recorded vote
then members need to uh indicate whether
or not they're voting for
against or abstaining because that will
be recorded in the minutes with names as
well
counselor eves thank you
sorry could you repeat i i missed that
abstain
thank you council hawkway
again thank you
can't say oh no oh
okay councillor merrick
four councillor mrs shaw
four counts of mr shaw
four myself four
councillor stanley against
thank you has the western four chairman
thank you that's the williams thank you
chairman four
thank you councillor wilson thanks
chairman
thank you
this one moment members
we have eight members in favor
three against and two abstentions
that application is approved thank you
agenda item seven
which is land opposite 92
to 102 windermere avenue
home bridge mr strengths is going to
present on this one
thank you chairman um this application
is to a site
of some four sorry 0.46 hectares
of open land on the southern side of
windermere venue shown
on the screen in the red square
the site is former greyhounds in land to
the front of the site is a hedge wide
verge area
with oakfield maple and hawthorne trees
the subject of tree preservation order
detached and semi-detached dwellings
from the northern side of windmill
avenue you can see opposite
the site to help orientate ourselves
before we jump to the other plans
i just asked members to focus on the
rectangular building to the
west of the site okay
um if you can point to the outbuilding
yvonne on the curser
hopefully remember if we go across to
the bottom of i think it's west avenue
there you go
that that triangular sorry rectangular
building there if members bear that in
mind as we jump to the next
plan if we could look at the next plan
please
leave the policy ser too
it's just is part of a wider allocation
there may be some confusion with people
about the fact that this is part of the
barrett david wilson
site and hopefully in the next couple of
plans we'll see that isn't if we can see
it's a smaller scale but if we can see
that
that outbuilding that we was just
focusing on for a moment is up there
where the cursor is now
the parcel of land is the next square
over that's it where the cursor is in
there we're talking about that plot of
land chairman which
we'll recall was released from the green
belt
in 2014 if we can see the malian site
layout
this next plan is the barrett david
wilson homes development that's curry
under construction and again you'll see
where the cursor is
we're talking about that white box of
land up the top there it's not part of
the
of the outline planning permission um
that is and the detail that is that is
being built
if we can jump to the site plan
for the proposal the current application
is for 17 dwellings chairman
it comprises 11 four-bedroom houses
we'll see
two pairs fronting windermere avenue
and then two pairs across the back with
a terrace of three
between them fronting a shared surface
road the terrace of three is where the
cursor is you see now
and then a block of uh six flats four
one bedroomed and two two-bedroomed
where the cursor is now on the
right-hand side as you would enter the
development
um the flatted accommodation would
satisfy the requirements for the
affordable housing in this scheme
particularly the smaller household size
that dominate the council's
waiting list the remaining houses that
you see
would be privately sold
in terms of gardner as the layout would
provide rear gardens in a conventional
arrangement
you can see there members will see at
paragraph 3.75 to report that
three terrace dwellings and the pair are
semi to the west
they are slightly under in the required
garden space by somewhere
six and a half square meters or less
each but that the spaces are never the
less usable as we can see there
and although that's disappointing uh
officers feel that it would not amount
in itself to a reason
uh for withholding consent particularly
whereas in this case a condition
removing permitted development rights
would bring future extensions under
control
and where the issue can be considered in
the light of the policies of the day
the apartment block however would enjoy
a very spacious
setting with the screen front garden
area to double the amenity space
required so that we
use it in the front of the building
because of the screening and the setting
and the setting of it usually amenity
space is tucked behind the building
because the
the buildings are so close to the to the
highway
in terms of side isolation space you'll
see at paragraph 365 to the report
that the layout will provide more than
the minimum side spaces to the dwellings
and that in parking terms the layout
will provide two car parking spaces for
each of the houses to
the preferred standard the six flats
would be served by the eight car parking
spaces required and there are five
visitor spaces throughout the
development
achieving the necessary visitor spaces
so the car parking that is shown would
meet the council standards at paragraph
367-371 of the report you'll
have seen that the dwellings would
achieve or exceed the requirements in
terms of national space for gross floor
space
where there may be a shortfall in
storage space this is more than marked
up by
excess of the overall growth in terms of
trees and ecology issues
members will see from the report that
details the layout
um there's a recommendation for tree
protection
measures in relation to the trees at the
front as you can see there and
the applicants have demonstrated the
root protection areas
um in the sort of pink line and the
circles that you can see at the top of
the drawing
in terms of ecology there are no
identified issues
the increased impact of future
recreational pressure from
future occupiers of the development is
cut on the on the estuary
is covered by the rams payment which is
feature of the legal agreement
now if we can see the five plan please
for the street scene
members will know that holbridge is a
mixture of development styles
often reflecting uh different tastes the
designs propose favor a mixed palette of
materials of render and brickwork
with articulation and visual interest
here in the form of entrance statements
or projecting
gables you'll see on the flatted block
there's also variation in the
form with the central area slightly
higher than
the adjoining flanks you'll note that
the window pattern is very strong
following a good window relationship
they're all on vertical and horizontal
axis
and the designs are either full three
stories as you'll see
or they incorporate rooms in the roof
ranging in height between 9.41 metres
and 10.67 meters across the scheme
and these are about one meter or so
higher than the designs approved to the
neighbouring
david wilson homes development council
of policy expects a minimum density of
30 dwellings per hectare
this scheme would meet that expectation
at 37 per hectare
officers consider the development is
proposed as a good design
and therefore the recommendation
chairman is approval subject to the
applicants known as entering to legal
agreement under section 106
of the act to the heads of terms set out
and to the conditions set out in the
report
thank you we have one uh speaker on this
this one planning agent mr paul hages
thank you chairman and uh good evening
members uh thank you for the opportunity
to
speak this evening and thank you can i
just say you have five minutes on this
one sorry
yeah thank you thank you for the
opportunity
uh to speak this evening and thank you
mike for the presentation
strat and parker the are the planning
consultants acting on behalf of
the applicant marlon homes wildland
homes are a local mid-tier developer
who have delivered numerous high-quality
and bespoke schemes in essex and the
wider south
east area priding themselves in
providing high quality developments
you've had the chance to read the
detailed report prepared by the case
officer which confirms that the
principle of development for this site
is established for its allocation under
policy ser
6b in the 2014 allocations plan
and of course national support for the
efficient use of land
as set out in the national planning
policy framework
that can has worked closely with the
council and statutory consultants
both at pre-application stage and during
the applications consultation process
to ensure that this scheme meets all
local and national
policy requirements such as parking
internal space standards
drainage and private immunity
the scheme has also been designed to
allow for the retention of existing head
droves and trees along the site
boundaries
with careful regard had for the
protected oak trees along the front of
the site
particularly with input from the
council's tree officer
as such there are no outstanding
objections from technical consultees
with ultimate details requested to be
provided by condition
the scheme was also significantly
redesigned during the lifetime of the
application
with direction provided by place
services urban design
which resulted in built form being set
further back from windermere avenue
increased immunity space for apartments
and improved cohesion with new
development adjacent to the site the
scheme provides 35
affordable housing in the form of six
apartments alongside section 106
contributions
the applicant has also proposed to
resurface windermere avenue
the app can also work with the council
to prepare a construction method
statement under the proposed condition
to ensure appropriate access
arrangements and to ensure durakai
regard for existing residents during any
future construction process
we hope that is carefully designed site
presents a positive opportunity for the
delivery of new homes
along with the other merits that
development will provide
and therefore that you are able to agree
with recommendation to
approve the development of this
sustainably located site
which has been allocated for residential
development
thank you thank you
councillor mr hoy please
thank you chairman um
i believe there are grounds for both
refusal of this application and
for deferral and i'm sure councillors on
the committee will decide which one
they're most in favor of i think it's
unlikely
they they would consider approval um
first of all i want to take you through
a couple of points around where i think
it might be for deferral
the report continually refers to
windermere avenue
to which this site would access as
highway
3.3 in the report unadopted highway
3.95 unadopted road three
um 3.93 again on an unadopted highway
or road sorry 3.94
again refers it to it as a highway 3.96
again refers to it as a
highway in relation to section 106. um
interestingly window avenue at that
point is not
a public highway um people may struggle
understand the concept of this
but if you live in holbrook you will
understand this there are things called
unadopted roads
and west avenue is unadopted windermere
avenue
is an adopted highway up to number 61.
between
number 61 and the junction of windermere
avenue
at west avenue it is just not a highway
it's not recognized
by essex highways as a highway an
unadopted road
is a public highway and it's a public
right-of-way so the first
problem i have with the application is
that it's accessing
onto windermere windermere avenue at a
point where it's not
a public highway there is no right of
way for anyone to use it in
legally as far as i can tell house
holders who own the road could block it
off
there's no access points so this is why
i'm saying possibly deferral i think
that needs to be clarified with people
how this would work and i understand
ownership is not an issue for planning
but i think this is something that needs
consideration
and i i would like the members to
consider it
in addition the report is again wrong
it's referring to the fact that
in 3.99 it says that
the unadopted highway of windermere
avenue
um comes onto the adopted highway
network at ferry road
well it doesn't it windermere avenue is
adopted highway from number 61 to number
one
where it is on free road the report is
incorrect
and i have problems with that i think if
members are making a decision on an
incorrect report
there we have problems um the other area
i think might be
calls for deferral is um around
secured by design the police clearly say
that this hasn't been done
and this should be done i don't think
it's good enough for us to leave it as a
condition
um there are those two points
i will now move on to the next ones
which is around
density and over development i'm aware
of the
minimum 30 drains per hectare which this
meets however it is building
to 37 per hectare there was a lot of
time
spent on ser 2 by members and by the
development committee which include the
refusal of the original
planning application by derek uh barrett
david wilson holmes although they did
withdraw it in the end i think the the
issue around this is that
the they they have gone to the effort
our david wilson home is putting of
putting a good design in
around density and it specifically says
around the upper the northern boundary
it states
in the application for the david wilson
home sites which isn't this one it's a
previous one but it abounds it
so the properties next to this site
relate to this it says
the northern quarter provides lower
density rural edge to the north fronting
windermere avenue
so we have gone to the effort of 500
properties going in on ser
2 a and b to make the effort of
trying to fit the northern boundary into
windermere avenue
and then we're completely trashing it by
saying well this doesn't matter we're
going to build a 37 hectares
completely over developed compared to
the neighbouring site at that point
i think this is a reason on its own for
refusal because it is not in keeping
with the new site at that point or
a game with windermere avenue windermere
avenue is a
road of detached and semi-detached
houses
um with some bungalows it is
at a quite a low density so i'd agree up
to 30 yes but 37 is
too much um
i'll now move on to the building height
these properties are three stories tall
even the ones in not just the flats
the rest are three stories tall there
are very very few
three-story properties in holbrook i
think they're the only ones are on the
new site
and down towards the river where there's
some townhouses
and that is it this is not appropriate
for for holbridge
and additionally barrett david wilson
homes
on the original application had three
story properties
towards the top of the site they removed
them
because they understood that they stood
out when you're driving along the whole
bridge road
the the site itself is very prominent
and it's a hill rising up
and if these properties go in at three
stories tall
they're going to dominate the skyline of
of the site
they would dominate it in a in a way
that isn't characterful
to hold bridge the properties in
windermere avenue
are residential houses three four
bedroom houses generally
the the flats coming onto windermere
avenue
opposite these houses are not
appropriate there are no flatted blocks
on the new development
near this site the flatted blocks will
put in the high density
area towards the middle of the site so
by
the the fact that these people chose not
to to sell to
david wilson homes means that they're
trying to to build
a site which is clearly over development
of the site in comparison to what was
what was seen as good design by barrett
david wilson homes and i don't want to
see that good design
ruined by this application and i hope
members bear that in mind the you're
about your five minutes now council
okay the amenity space for five
properties is below amenity space
there is no access to the amenity space
by foot
from this site to the new site parking
standards and i'll bring this up
now there are undercroft parking parking
against the wall for clarity mike
strength might like to refer
to uh paragraph 3.2.7 of the essex
parking
design guide which states that where a
parking space is against a hard boundary
they should allow another meter so if
these are under cross parking spaces
the parking spaces would be wider i've
seen nothing in the report to
say to me that the parking standard can
be met can you sum up now please then
the amenity space is clearly not met
um so on those great grounds i think the
grounds refuse will put
our density over development out of
character with the street scene
the building heights are inappropriate
for the area
the amenity space is undersized
and the parking spaces do not meet
standard okay thank you
um i've no other non-members indicating
so move on to member
discussion now so uh first of all
please counselor stanley i'm sorry
if you wouldn't mind cancer stanley i'll
let councillor wilson go first
as he's a ward counsellor there
councillor wilson
yeah sorry chairman um yeah um really to
follow on from what uh council has said
one of
one of the um concerns i've got
is of over development and in paragraph
3.18
of the officers report it says that the
planning application has not been
supported by evidence
that the development is required to
maintain a five-year land supply
um and so that reinforces council hoy's
point about this
the density of the development for uh 37
properties per hectare compared with the
david wilson homes
30 um properties per hectare
in that that section um
the i've got this this one is a question
rather than a statement
um and it's to the officers really that
paragraph 3.77 of
the report um it goes on
it explains about the um lack of amenity
space which is a concern which has been
raised by council hawaii
but it says that it might be necessary
to remove permitted development rights
in order to safeguard amenities space
provision
but i'm not sure with with recent
changes to
legislation and and policy uh government
policy
whether that would actually be
enforceable or not because actually
the the um removal of rights
would to me appear to be against
the the policy from government
department
um again just to really emphasize the
point
that the council hoi made about the
height of the buildings
the this literally is the highest point
in holbridge and
it's 20 meters above sea level and at
the lowest point
holdbridge road where it joins lower
road
is zero meters above sea level
so it's actually quite a steep slope and
i i objected to the david wilson's homes
when they sighted
the three-story buildings on on the same
um height level because it would
dominate the skyline it would be
it would just be too much for the
skyline um and they did
as councilman said move those down the
hill and so i would say that
the height of these is first of all
overbearing
because of the the topology but also
in relation to the um neighboring
properties as well
um and the the the
final point really is that um i'm
concerned that we've had no comment from
essex highways now that
i know our officers have asked for one
but i would expect for a development
of of this size and where it is in
relation to the other developments
um to be to be there that to provide the
report for us and
i would uh i would welcome them to try
and get that report
thank you chairman thank you council
stanley
thank you chairman um
apart from these uh
items that have been put forward by
uh councillor weston and
mark councillor hoy um
that i'd like to put a proposal in
that this is uh
put back to the developer on the basis
of
over development and and
uh the height the height of the
buildings are
too strong for that site as well as
and i note here that there's no
uh details of the water drainage
uh surface water from the site and where
that's going to go is it going to go
into the reservoirs or of the
barrett homes uh reservoirs or or how
that's going to be dealt with as that's
at the top of the
slope which we've we already understand
and and also to uh to defer it to
to the developer or to another time
uh on the basis of the road is
is a adopted road and not unadopted road
rather
and not adopted by by the council um
i think there are several reasons there
to to defer it um and
uh yeah i want to put that forward as a
proposal please
so just for clarity you're
you're you're putting forward a
motion to defer yes
on on on the ground just for clarity can
you just
sta state those clearly so the officers
have time to
note those down again please yeah um
over development in in the case of
height um also that the
western road is unadopted um
which it doesn't show it's unadopted
and also the surface water
uh how that's going to be dealt with um
there's no
we've got no no plans of that
or all anything um
the what was the other thing
um councillor wilson spoke
off i can't put words into your mouth
no i know you can't um would you like me
to am i able to speak
could i ask you hold on a minute please
you just keep an order and another
members indicated
yeah could i ask for advice from uh
councillor wilson
on i can't remember what you said please
counselor wilson would you just like to
help out councillor stanley
my pleasure chair um yes it was to do
with the
density of the development so
the proposed density is 37 buildings per
hectare
and the
compared to the barrett david wilson
adjacent site which is 30
and we deliberately took that it was the
height of the buildings i think
that you've got which is out of out of
context um it was to do with essex
highways
um it was to see if officers could get
um
guidance from essex highways and it's
not just that the roads are not
sorry are unadopted it's that they are
not shown as highways full stop
and so whether whether people will be
able to get
access from that the secured by design
element from the essex police service
and i think that was all i think you've
got the rest of my points as well and in
the parking i believe
and parking standards okay
they're noted so
sorry i did miss one off as well i've
got a million pieces of paper
and the other one was the amin lack of
immunity space and whether we
can with government policy changing
whether in regard to the pd yeah yeah
thank you
thank you chairman councillor wilson i
didn't actually hear
although you contributed to cancer
stanley i didn't actually hear you
second
his motion for deferral uh i'd like to
second it
yes okay thank you councillor weston
we're speaking on the motion for
deferral now please
um okay uh i would just wanted to agree
with the other other members um
again i think one of my main points is
the unadopted road and
not in keeping with the street scene
along windermere avenue
uh the height and the other development
if they feel they want to defer it i'm
happy to
um agree with them thank you chairman
thank you
um i'll ask mr stranks to comment on
that
but i must admit in the items that have
been listed
are i'm i'm not absolutely
absolutely comfortable with all of those
items because some of them are
things that clearly you didn't agree
with within the design
others were items where you felt
you required greater clarity and those
are two different things
i believe that within the application we
have enough information to make
a decision but i do understand that
there may be some issues where you
feel that you need greater clarity
before you come to a decision
however mr strengths would you care to
comment on what has been suggested
please
thank you chairman um i'll try and
capture everything
that i've noted down in terms of the
highway we were able to
contact the agents in the run-up to
committee
um to clarify the highway issue and they
advised us from ringway jacobs who are
essex county's
contractors that the the land does have
highway rights and if you think about it
the houses that you'll see across the
top of the
uh the site front in windermere avenue
they'll access over that at the current
time
it's it's known um it seems as what they
call a private street
so it enjoys highway rights for access
but is not
publicly maintained so it's not what you
would refer to as an adopted street
but the the applicants are quite clear
that they've been checking it out with
their solicitors i think in the run-up
to submitting the planning application
they're quite clear that they've got
access rights that would
give them the opportunity to access the
site on the
pd rights question
the government's ambition is that yes
there would be freedoms from planning
control for acceptable forms of
development
and those pd rights these days are quite
extensive and we will see an example of
that later
but the planning authority where it sees
it necessary
it can mitigate a harm um such as the
garden areas that we've
we as officers have alerted you to to
say well
the problem we have in defending reasons
for hughes and gardiner is and you'll
recall the the refusal of one of the
david wilson home schemes at christmas
tree farm in hawker some years ago
that the inspector took a view that it's
a usable space
and it's a few square meters short
that's not like we see on some
schemes where the developer may be
trying to squeeze all the car parking in
and puts a bit of amenity space left
over there and another bit over there
and
they're not connected and you know you
get 10 square meters here 20 square
meters there
they don't form one complete hole this
layout
forms usable garden spaces albeit just
under
your standard and the
um in officer's view it wouldn't stand
up as a reason
for refusal on the lack of of garden
space
um now with secure by design i take the
point i believe the architects have
had that in mind but they they wouldn't
get certification
until after i think that they've they've
built it
but i'm not saying that the scheme is
secured by design
compliant it doesn't have to be it's
just something that is
that is desirable in terms of the height
and
the over development issue it's in
members gift as to
how they feel about the development i i
emphasized at the beginning of the
presentation
the issue with the outlying consent this
is not part of that outline consent or
that developers philosophy in developing
the 500 dwellings
it's a judgment call as to whether this
scheme
is successful or not and members may be
right
and they're clearly aware of the history
in terms of the desire
to move high buildings away but you'll
see from the report that officers have
taken into consideration the
relationship
between the buildings on the site and
the setting
uh particularly the flatted building
there's a substantial open space
between the street and the position in
the building
now it may well be that homes along that
avenue
have enjoyed over many years looking
over farmland
but we can't safeguard their views
of the landscape much as we might like
to
you have to look at the the merits of
the development in its own right
if you compare that to streets behind
windermere avenue i think it's the drive
or grasmere that's behind
you know those people don't have that
that outlook and is it reasonable to
to require that the buildings are lower
in scale members may take a view that it
is reasonable
and you know they're at liberty to do so
but officers have looked at this and the
setting and the quality of the design
and in our view our recommendation to
you um
is that this is this is acceptable
you'll see that there are comments from
the urban design team
who are favorable towards the design
um i think chairman i did have one or
two
breakages in the in the communication
but
hopefully i think i've covered what was
uh one other point about the
land supply um that was a point to the
development plan the the fact where the
officer has picked up
that there isn't no support in uh
information for the
for the uh numbers is speaking to the
allocation issue
where the uh the allocation that you
laid down
said that extra dwellings if you like
uplift
on the site we're seeing across a number
of sites
may be justified if it's necessary for
the council's housing supply
and the council's housing supply is on
or about five years
so the applicants i think have not felt
it essential that they justify this
extra
amount because bear in mind that this
this site that we're looking at
is still part of the application the
david wilson homes development does not
take 100
of the application of the allocation
sorry so
it's a site that isn't green belt it's
available for development
and the extra dwellings the few here of
17 or so
would no doubt help the council's
position with with the supply of
uh um homes thank you
thank you um members we
we've got a motion for deferral
on on points that that have been made um
mr strengths has talked about them i
don't believe that we need to
go back to further explore those things
um so i would like to go to the vote
fairly soon on this
council uh i'll come back to you
councillor stanley
last as the person that proposed the
deferral
so we'll just uh anyone else indicating
apart from councillor wilson
and cancer stanley okay
we'll deal with those two then we'll go
to the vote on this councillor wilson
thank you chairman it was really just to
follow on from um
what mr strength has just said there was
um i'm still not clear about the right
of way
um i've i've looked at the public right
of way
okay you you've got that as a reason
to be explored within your deferral yeah
so unless you're looking to take it out
i think we can move on
okay it's just for clarification because
it i think mr strength gave the
impression
that um there was a public right of way
along there and it's not clear from the
essex highways public right-of-way
website that that's my point
and the second one was um just to again
to clarify
mr shrank said about the overlook sorry
the views
of um residents in windermere avenue
that wasn't the point that was being
made the point was that
these are two two and a half three
storey buildings and
are out of context there it's nothing to
do with people losing
thank you thank you cancer stanley if
you would like to
sum up and then just to restate for
absolute clarity
the reasons for your deferral please
thank you chairman um the reasons for
deferral is uh design
uh overbearing um where there are no
other uh buildings of that particular
height
um also uh the parking stand
standard that we hold and also the
uh unadopted
road that was put in or is is there as
unadopted and not adopted
as as mentioned by mr strengths
um
yeah i think that's that's where we
stand
okay right thank you members we have a
motion for deferral but followed by
councillor stanley
seconded by councillor wilson
councillor hawkway your hands suddenly
gone up
yes yes sir chairman just um it was just
a point that
um i'm sure as part of the deferment it
was mentioned about the lack of
amenities
space was mentioned i know councillor
stanley was summing up
and i think he missed that off because
i'm sure that was part of the original
uh deferment is that
is that accurate cancer stanley yes
you're right
thank you thank you so can i
ask if members would like
a recorded vote on this
the threshold has been passed therefore
i'll call the vote
you're going to say for deferral against
referral
deferral or abstain just confirm that
everyone is clear about
what their in what they're voting on
okay we'll go to the vote then
council butcher
four councillor fd
for woody film and chairman
councillor eaves four make a chairman
okay cancel the hookway
four go cassiano
four thank you that's the merrick
oh okay councillor sure
this is sure oh okay councillor mr shaw
four thank you um myself
i'll vote for cancer stanley
four joe cancer western
four chairman thank you councillor
williams
uh thank you chairman against
okay councillor wilson
four chairman thank you
i think that's clear i
don't i don't think i need to wait for
the confirmation sonia i have 12
4 1 against and no
abstentions so that item
is deferred thank you
next we have number 41
crown hill rayleigh mr strangs is
presenting
again on this one when you're ready
please
thank you chairman if we could see one
location plan please
um for this item if members bear with us
while we
clear the screen of the last item
um we'll see in a moment that this
application is to a site on the southern
side
of crown hill west of raleigh town
centre
um if we got the location plan first
that would be
we can use this if that's difficult but
i'll give you a moment to find that's it
that's one one plan
right right the hard left that's it try
that
great no that's the last one
we move on this application has been
before us before members and members
will recall that it's an existing
bungalow
uh relatively set back in relation to
the street
and the bungalow are joining at number
39 which you can see on the
on the left hand side of the site plans
shown to you
and the house at number 45 which is
slightly more forward
um to the west the site is subject to an
outline plan admission with all matters
reserved for a
two-story building to contain five flats
um this outline permission established
the principle of the development to be
acceptable but with matters of sighting
design appearance scale access
landscaping to be held for consideration
at a later stage what we call a reserve
matters
application an earlier reserve matters
application utilizing the existing
access was refused permission for
reasons of scale bulk height
depth and three-story form poor
relationship with the neighbouring
dwellings particularly upon the house to
number 45
and that the layout then proposed which
you can see on the left hand of your
screen
dice mr strength i'm sorry for
interrupting chairman it's council
wilkinson can i just raise a point at
this point please it's important no
counselor wilkinson um no
no no you can't the officer they stuck
diagrams incorrect
the officer is the old one the officer
must continue to present their request
it's the wrong diagram you can deal with
the point of order
afterwards
chairman if i may yeah thank you um to
clarify to members i am
deliberately showing the old drawing
where i was
because it's important to rehear to
bring members up to speed with the
inspectors findings i will show
the proposed plan in a moment but if you
i need members to look at the left hand
side of the screen
and you'll see the larger gray image of
the
is if you like a bird's eye view of
showing the sheer sort of volume mass
and extent of built form
and what we'll end up talking about is
the car parking spaces across the front
of the building this is the
refused scheme that was considered by an
inspector
now as i was saying the scale and bulk
of that building and the poor
relationship particularly emphasized
with number 45 if you see the depth
of built form going beyond the rear
corner of number 45
that was an issue with members before as
well as the inadequacy of the car
parking members felt that a lot more car
parking spaces
should be provided now the inspector
went on to
consider this application that you see
here as an appeal
and in dismissing that appeal the
inspector didn't agree with the council
on the scale bulk and depth
three-story form issue he didn't agree
with the council on the poor
relationship to number 45
okay so those issues if you like are
lost the inspector has
ruled on that and they become a material
consideration of some strength
what the inspector did consider
was the car parking spaces you can see
on the front in front of the building
in this earlier scheme we haven't yet
shown you the proposed scheme
but this earlier scheme were to the
minimum size
and the inspector when he come to look
at the appeal he realized that the
outline permission had said only five
when necessary because your
policy allows some relaxation where
you're close to the town center
but he noted a conflict between the
manual for the streets
which accepts that the minimum sizes
as opposed to the council's own guidance
through essex
for a preferred larger size now this is
the scheme that's refused if we can
just hopefully jump to the floor plans
and elevations before we look at the new
site plan
just to give member members a gauge of
if we look at three plan
floor plan and elevations please just
give members a size or a reminder of the
sort of massing and bulk of the building
that that's the one
this this application that's before us
today
is identical in design and form but for
one
change externally i don't know if yvonne
you can
go to the uh right of the proposed
left-hand side elevation
and you'll see a brickwork projection
beyond
the the rendered corner obvious that's
where your cursor is there on the front
elevation if you can just ask it if
you're there
there's been an increase in depth of 0.8
of a meter forward
towards um crown hill that's the only
external
design change to what the cons the
inspector
previously previously considered
so if we can go to the the new layout
plan please
for plan layout plan this chairman
is the current proposal that's for your
consideration tonight
so you'll see that the layout has been
changed the parking spaces that were
across the front of the building have
been turned through 90 degrees
and you'll see hopefully clearly there
spaces one and five
are to the minimum size but spaces 2 3
and 4
have been put in at the preferred bay
size
of 5.5 by 2.9 so
when the inspector looked at the
previous car parking he was
critical that they were all on the
minimum and he felt with five flats in
the scheme there would be a variation of
vehicle size
suitable to small households so he he
argued for a mix of spaces
and the applicant has responded to this
the applicant has put in three to your
preferred
standard and two to the minimum
standard now the applicant if we can
look at five plan vehicle tracking
the applicant was also required because
the inspector felt that it wasn't clear
if these spaces would work
now you'll see from the representations
that have been received there is some
criticism
of these uh diagrams still there's a
criticism that
they may not work there's even a
criticism that i think if you look
carefully you might see that
the the space on the right hand side may
have moved slightly
we've rehearsed this with our colleagues
at county highways and we've asked them
um how robust these are and it's a bit
of a surprising view really they've said
because of the oversized
space which remember we prefer and they
encourage
there's more scope and variation in your
maneuverability
so county highways aren't uh objecting
to this arrangement whether these
swept path movements are actually truly
representative remains to be seen
but our colleagues at highways are are
confident that if
laid out as proposed on these drawings
forget the vehicle movements for a
moment but if the
if the layout proposed to the front
they're confident it would work
so chairman given that the inspector
found that the previous objections to
design and form
were acceptable and that the applicant
has addressed the need to provide a
better mixing spaces as
identified by the inspector the
recommendation is approval subject to
the conditions set out in the report
thank you we have uh two speakers
on this one uh first mr
wilkinson who is the applicant
please five minutes uh
uh thank you mr chairman and good
evening members um
i may just be repeating a few things
that the
planner himself there has said but i'll
go through it anyway
it's not
thank you okay go ahead please okay
thank you and before going into the
finer details i
would just like to emphasize one point
uh regarding the outline planning
permission for the five plants
um in our outline permission we did
state that they would all be two
bedrooms and in a layout of two on the
ground floor
two on the first floor and the fifth on
the top story
this is confirmed in the officers report
in section 2.3
also in section in her report in section
2.4
it confirms that the outline planning
requires a development to make a
provision for five car parking spaces
it's just in the previous committee
meeting i'm not sure this was made clear
so i just wanted to highlight those
facts um
i'd also like to highlight as the
planner has said uh previously the
reserve matters were sent to appeal
and the government inspector was happy
with the development size
bulk and how it looked within the street
scene in fact the inspector only had
two issues he would like rectified his
first which was mentioned in the
officers report
in section 3.13 is and i quote
it is likely that there would be some
requirement for spaces of the preferred
spa
size and suggested a mix of provisions
in terms of parking space sizes
we've now made three of those five
spaces larger spaces and they meet the
requirements of the preferred size
of the remaining two although slightly
smaller in width
but still meeting the minimum
requirements one is adjacent a path
and the second is adjacent to the
turning area in the car park
so we'll still allow a larger vehicle to
fit in them and the doors can open fully
onto the area next to the space
the turning area for the cars as the uh
planner has just confirmed
is also of course suitable for the
maneuvering of larger vehicles
and so they can enter the street front
first
and as he also said they do meet all the
standards of essex highways
so not only have we created a mix of
spaces as requested
all the spaces will now accommodate
larger vehicles comfortably
i'm pleased to hear the spanner the
planner also agrees that this can no
longer be a reason to refuse planning
permission
the second reason was regarding the
juliet balcony on the back
[Music]
of the first floor rear flat and i think
the planning officer
uh summed up nice in her report i think
uh she something up so well
um the planner there didn't even mention
it but i'll i'll adjust for the sake of
it
um the planning in sp and this is uh a
quote from section 3.21 of her report
the planning inspector expressed a
concern with regards to the privacy
screen that would flank a terrorist at
the first floor
the first floor real rear balcony
element has now been removed
from the proposed development and
therefore the objection raised by the
planning inspector that led to the
previous appeal being dismissed
now falls away regarding the development
in general the council planner concludes
in her report
section 6.1 is considered that the
reasons
for refusal on the grounds previously
identified and tested at a pill
could now not be sustained i hope you
can appreciate that there are only two
issues that the planning inspector
decided that planning permission could
be refused
and we have completely resolved those
now there are no longer any valid
planning reasons to refuse a development
on a side note from previous experience
at the last committee
the speaker who will argue against our
development will in his unqualified
opinion come up with all sorts of things
he thinks we've not done correctly
whether it's the size of the building
the size of the refuse store
the turning area in the car park but i
just want to
reiterate we meet all planning
requirements
there is not a single statutory
consultant
from the council refuse department to
essex highways etcetera
the professionals who are qualified to
assess such matters
have any problems with our plans thank
you
thank you
our next speaker is mr hind
we just hold on a second and we'll get
your share screen up
okay um you're if you'd like to begin
you have
five minutes please thank you mr kevin
my name is phil hind and i live next
door to the site we object to this
proposal for the following reasons
the amendments do not address the
concerns raised by the planning
inspector
next slide this submission gives details
for a three-storey building with a
footprint of 195 square meters when
outline planning permission next slide
was only granted for a two-story
building with a footprint of 154 square
meters
our objection letter provides full
details but in summary
overlooking the pi gives no
consideration of the proposed balconies
overlooking the most private amenity
areas of 12
leesway on the living rooms of 30 and 32
crown hill
the 45 degree angle the pi notes that
the spd states that the 45 degree
measurement should be taken from the
nearest edge of the window of the
adjacent property
proposed proposals persist in bending
this policy
taking it from the centre line based on
an appeal where the properties involved
were built before the 45 degree rule was
introduced
this bears little relevance to a new
build where the policy should be
enforced as documented
on-site parking the pi's document
logically builds towards his final
summary he recognizes that families
could apply
could occupy this development and they
would need suitable vehicles
so the developer was requested to
provide
proof that large family vehicles could
maneuver on the drive in order to
satisfy safety concerns
the schematics do not fulfill this
request for two reasons
incorrect car size next slide the top
horizontal space is five meters long and
the car easily fits within it
we know that the pi states that a large
family vehicle will overhang a five
meter space
the car they have used is one meter too
short next slide
the space from the horizontal parking
spaces to the vertical space is six
meters which means that the simple
reverse and drive straight out here
shown is unrealistic
two inconsistent maneuvering scenarios
next slide
the vertical parking space has to move
to make the schemes work
this is a movement of over half a meter
parking bay sizes
the pi attempts to determine whether
this development justifies the
exceptional circumstance that allows the
use of smaller parking spaces
and discusses why this is not the case
he briefly considers an option that a
mix of provision
may be justified it does not say it is
justified he does say that there should
be provision for larger family vehicles
to be able to use any of these spaces
he concludes that the development should
provide car parking in accordance with
spd
2.9 meters by 5.5 meters
there is no mention that this
development warrants being an
exceptional circumstance
anywhere in his argument access next
slide
the pi states that there are access
areas on the driveway that cannot be
allocated to parking because they are
access areas
the vertical parking space blocks access
to the front door
being a smaller space it is likely that
the vehicle will be parked away from the
boundary to give the driver access thus
encroaching into the turning space
even further than is shown in the
diagram the small top horizontal parking
space reduces access to the side path
where the bins are stored to less than a
meter
if the downstairs windows are open this
reduces even further
parking off-site for visitors the pi has
criticised the council for relaxing its
own spt guidelines which state two
parking spaces per two bedroom flat
plus a quarter visitor space per flat he
recognizes that there is no provision
for
visit visitor parking but states there
is little substantive evidence this will
have an impact on surrounding roads
he visited the site on the 10th of june
during the national lockdown when
schools and shops were shut
next slide this was the situation in
lee's ways on tuesday this week
the bins with up to 20 residents and a
275 square meter garden one small bin
for food and garden waste will be
insufficient
maintenance will be unable to take
garden waste away as they won't be able
to park on or near the property
axis access to the bins is unsuitable
the ability to maneuver the bins in the
proposed location is unrealistic
space is a premium so this has to be
addressed before planning permission is
granted
incorrect bat survey next slide there
are bats that fly around in our gardens
there are considerable less since the
developers destroyed all these trees
just over four minutes this 1950s
property fulfills your criteria for a
detailed bat survey this has already
been pointed out numerous times
next slide it is your responsibility to
enforce this
in summary outline and reserve matters
don't match
the planning department are considering
allowing this developer broke their
rules on the 45 degree line
the number of parking bays per bedroom
visitor parking and now the size of the
parking bays what is the point of having
an spd
safety issues with access to and from
the site incorrect bat survey
compromised access
being allocation access no
infrastructure for electric vehicles
insufficient additional surface water
management
residents are not opposed to this site
being redeveloped but it must be within
the council's own guidelines and not
detrimental to future occupants
or neighbors thank you thank you
uh counselor wilkinson you have
indicated as a visiting member
if you'd like to go ahead please okay
chairman thank you i'm gonna have to
move my
ipad i do apologize i hope because i
need to be able to see my screen
on my other device um firstly the reason
why i interrupted before chairman i
apologize um i know that mr strength was
struggling with the
slides and i thought he'd just got the
wrong one out that was all chairman
members i wish to support
the representations already expressed
deceiving by mr mrs hind
the residents who live directly next
door to this application site
this application before you this evening
is the fourth application submitted to
russia district council for this site
the initial one being for outline
permission in february 2019
this together with the previous two were
to consider the reserved matters
relating to the detail of the proposal
that in itself should be indicative of
the applicant's apparent inability to
engage with residents who already live
in crown hill who will be affected by
this development
and also their inability to listen to
the already well documented and recorded
concerns raised by this committee
chairman what makes this worse in my
submission
is that the last application on being
refused went to appeal
an appeal which the applicant lost yes
here we are again without the necessary
alterations despite what he says without
the necessary alterations required to be
made and the planning department have
advised you to approve it
the the initial the initial outline
planning consent was made
on the 27th of february 2019.
in the consent letter it states the
permission is granted
based on two drawings submitted as part
of the application
for a two story premises with a total
area of 154 square meters
as we've already heard this application
yet again
is for a three-story building with an
area of 194 square meters which is an
increase
of somewhere in the region 25 over what
was originally agreed in the outline
planning consent
therefore this application cannot rely
on previously obtained outline planning
consent to allow you to grant it as it
does not fit within the degree
the terms of that outline consent in
addition
if we look at the application which was
submitted last time which was refused
due to scale height bulk etcetera the
dimensions
of those are exactly the same however
this time has already been pointed out
it's actually bigger it's come out
further
so rather than listening to the concerns
of the committee last time relating to
the scale
bulk and height the applicant has
actually decided to increase it
the only aspect of the previous
application which has been been revised
has been a removal of the real balcony
and spinning the car parking places
through 90 degrees
at the last meeting valid reasons for
refusal points one and two
have not been addressed at points one
and two at the last meeting
they have not been addressed and so
therefore still valid reasons for
refusal
in the inspector's report he dismisses
the applicant's appeal and he says in
paragraph 31 of that report
notwithstanding the lack of objection on
the part of the local highway authority
to the proposed parking arrangements i
do not consider
proposal has demonstrated that it makes
adequate provision for parking of
vehicles within the site
there is no provision made for visitor
parking within the site
and any unmet demand for this proposal
was likely to appear
on street and crown hill and nearby
streets are already subject to on-street
parking controls and you've seen a
photograph from the previous speaker
about what the local streets are like
and bearing in mind uh chairman and
members when you consider the
application in
great waking you've already heard this
evening there was discussion around
vista parking
the inspector then goes on to say in
paragraph 33 i find the proposal would
not make
adequate position provision for car
parking and therefore will be contrary
to policies dm1 dm3 and dm
30 amongst other things chairman in
summary
the applicant has not addressed the
reasons for this committee refusing the
last application
at all they have not addressed the
concerns the planning officer the
implanting inspector has when he
dismissed their appeal
the building is larger is still imposing
on the occupants of number 45.
three stories not two as per granted as
per the outline
um commission the pure facts are that
whilst in february 2019 this council
might have granted outline consent for
five flats on that site it was granted
on the basis that the building would be
a two-story building
it is clearly obvious to anybody who
looks this proposal is simply not
physical
physically possible to build five frats
into two stories on that site because
they've tried this the third time
they've tried
the area to the front is not sufficient
to comply with even a watered down
parking pot standard policy
which has been adjusted to accept the
transport links in the area which are
really good there is no visitor parking
and they're turning circles to allow the
vehicles to leave the site facing
forward
are not enough in essence they have
outlined permission
to build a building on the side which is
physically impossible to do within our
own regulations
it is about time that the developer and
the planning department recognize that
this plot is only big enough
for a two-story building with either
four flats contained
or a normal two-story house i echo the
comments made by mr pine
that i welcome development to that site
it's a derelict bungalow it needs
developing
but it is developing appropriately in
line with
the outline consent that was granted in
february 2019
and tr stop trying to squeeze every last
penny out of this
i would therefore not only urge you to
reject this application members
but to make it clear that this cannot
come before you again in this format
thank you chairman thank you
only no other non-members
not indicating members um it's for us to
discuss
now um i must remind you members
that we have to determine
our uh our decision purely on
planning matters and on and
on that theme we have had a
recent um inspectorate
examination of this application
of the previous application and some
very clear guidance as to
what they feel is acceptable what isn't
with regard to the parking issues
we have got a clear indication from
essex highways
who are the um consulting authority on
this
that they feel that it is appropriate
can i ask if any of the members
wish to speak or indicate
i'm not seeing any at this point oh
counselor stanley
thank you chairman um as the
we're on your daily are we first of all
can i ask are we dealing with this
application
or are we putting the previous
application
in with this application now
we are dealing with the application in
front of us tonight
the application is outlined by cancer
strengths okay
thank you thank you very much so uh okay
sorry mr strikes not council strengths
so okay so so
first of all may i begin with the the
proposal of the parking
um because the parking is
uh so close to the boundary to to the
side
um of the of the proposed parking i i
can't see how
uh and it's only 2.5 meters wide and not
2.9 meters wide
um that's going to be difficult for
anybody to get out
whether they're on the left side or the
right side depending on how they drive
in backwards or forwards
the other thing that really concerns me
is that there is no
invalid parking um for any visitors
um this is this is a concern that we
have raised many many times
in the council and it's something that
we
we uphold greatly when we when we have
uh properties being developed and and
in this situation of flats well we've
got no
disabled parking the other thing that
really comes to mind is that
if somebody is parked in the bay five
and somebody who wants to reverse out
from bay
2 and obviously they've driven in so
they've got need to reverse
and they've got nowhere to reverse it
doesn't actually show
the drawings submitted don't actually
show a part a car being parked
in bay five because it's not always
that they will want to use their car so
they will leave it in bay five
so the parking is is restricted somewhat
getting on to the building line um
this extends beyond the building line of
the neighbouring properties
and i feel that this is somewhat an
overburden to
to the neighbouring properties and also
the height which is a substance
it looks i don't know what i can't see
what the
height is but it looks quite quite
overbearing to the other properties
adjacent to either side of that property
uh i believe that yes um
the the depth of it goes way beyond
the other properties as well
it would be i don't know um
it seems to me that the the property
is overbearing to to the surrounding
properties in that neighborhood admitted
the further up the crown hill you go
the higher the buildings do go up
because it's not on level ground
so therefore the buildings do rise in in
height
nevertheless it is still predominantly
higher than the
neighbouring buildings
i don't see
we we we should i say
rejected it before on on the
bulk of of it and i i've believed that
we should
defer this on bulk parking
and on its size beyond
neighbouring properties thank you thank
you cancer fd
thank you chairman um i'm going to look
at what the inspector
rejected this on one of the reasons was
the parking and
being able to move move maneuver
out of the property in forward gear
and i know that
highways have said the maneuvering works
but it's sort of beggars belief
when the parking space moves between
diagrams
to actually make it work so
i don't know if highways need to look at
that again because i'm
disturbed that the actual diagram is not
the same all the way through
where it moves to make it work i and i
think that could be a reason for
rejection on this
thank you thank you council eves
thank you chair um a couple of things
that uh come to mind
um first of all the uh
reason for uh refusal before involved uh
bulgar mass it does strike me as
somewhat
dare i call it opportunist for the
developer to then increase the size of
the building
and rely on the um the report
uh previously or the appeal uh before a
decision
um as being met
and yet he's still trying to push the
boundaries somewhat so i i do kind of
question that i know it's not a massive
increase but he's still an increase
and so as that was a material
consideration that was considered an
appeal
i do wonder whether that is something
that actually needs to be revisited
because
the actual bulk of that has actually
changed
um the other thing is the parking issue
um
as the neighbor pointed out one thing
that concerns me is
when the inspector attended site um
there was no real problem with parking
on the street but i'm quite familiar
with that street and it does get very
uh blocked with parking down there um
and so i think there may be a good
reason to actually refer this back
to the inspector even because uh his
basis for making his decision um may
have been quite
um out of proportion for his uh
conclusion
thank you jack thank you council hawkway
thank you chairman um yes uh i think uh
it's been
already raised but the um but it's
obviously very significant it's the is
the
the modeling um that has been done
in relation to the parking spaces and
the
maneuver maneuvering of vehicles within
those
uh from those parking spaces uh access
into the parking spaces and then
access back onto the road um
and um it would
it does raise some questions as to
um you know
what was the size of the vehicle
that was used in the modeling because
as with a lot of these matters it's
it's all about uh the uh the information
that you put in
detent depends to determine the answers
that you get
and maybe um if um
if you if you want to try to uh get the
right answers you might
uh sort of look to um you know
be a bit kinder to the uh the
information that you want to put in so
i'd ask mr strix as to whether
he is aware or not knows what
was the size of the vehicle that was
done in the modelling
bearing in mind that the expector
specifically stated
um you know family sized vehicle um
in in relation to uh the the issues to
do with parking
um so uh whether whether it was
deemed as a family side vehicle whether
you know uh bear in mind that they these
uh vehicles are a lot larger nowadays
than what they
everyone that's indicated has had one
opportunity to speak
i'd like you to come back and deal with
those
those issues that covered around
uh parking for visitors building line
the the bulk and mass and the obviously
the
maneuvering issues and size of vehicles
around the car parking spaces please
thank you thank you chairman um it was
actually asked on an earlier item and
i'd overlooked that my apologies but
i was asked how we can exit a
uh minimum space a 2.5 by five well
it's a reality chairman that most of the
car parking spaces we use on a daily
basis at supermarkets and older premises
are all built to that earlier standard
now there are
difficulties with that if you have a
larger car the land rovers the suvs
things like this and i
accept that there are smaller cars that
you sometimes you go to drive in a space
and you don't realize they're there
but if these minimum spaces are operable
it's just that the county council and
the district council have a preferable
size to accommodate the larger vehicles
and
that's why we shoot for the larger for
the larger size
so the minimum size does work the manual
for streets which operates for the rest
of the country outside at essex
still go for five five by 2.5
i don't know if yvonne can put up the um
site plan
or the layout plan the current one if
that's possible because there was a
there was a comment there about building
lines
now i would counsel remember sorry
not not that one the um the site layout
that shows you joining properties
um no the site that's the one thank you
um
i would counsel members about
having rigid building lines where
everything
is in line it it can be a boring street
what you should have ideally is
respectful variety
now you'll see on this team with the
building being extended by 0.8 you'll
see i don't know if yvonne can see at
the top of space number one where the
grey
and there's a dimension there are 1396
if you take that across
which is the extended forward gable in
the refused scheme it was it was set
back point a to the meter
but you'll see a line there across if
yvonne likes to follow the dimension
line
that the sorry the lower one down the
forward one closer to crown hill
yep up up a little bit just a millimeter
or two
you'll see that line of the gray that
goes that's it cross to the corner of
the building with the bay windows
so you'll see that in this scheme the
applicant the extension proposed
is in line with number 39 and you'll see
that number 45 if you can go across to
car parking space five
about a meter or so down from the back
that's it that point there you'll see
the corner of number 45
is in front of this proposed dwelling so
it wouldn't be a case that you could say
this building would be forward of the
building line
the building line is probably varied
down that street anyway with the
curvature of the road but what
rather than follow a rigid setback line
they used to in the 60s which was deemed
wasteful of urban land
you have interest and variety and what
this gable
projection does and perhaps by
exaggerating it
it actually enhances the design makes
what the urban designers would call
articulation and a more interesting
feature
but it's a matter of taste but clearly
there is no encroachment over any
building line with that with that
projection there there has been comment
which i understand
given the representations made about the
bulk the size the overlooking etcetera
the inspector visited those issues they
were reasons for refusal last time
and my my laboring on that earlier
decision may have given members a false
impression that they were
revisiting those issues the reason i i
dwelled on those
was because last time round more or less
the same design but for the slight
alteration to the front
was considered by that inspector and
could because it
members refused permission for those
reasons for the impact on 45
and for the scale and the bulk of it and
the inspector dwelled on that in his
representations he
he looked at the the locality of the
area and
didn't feel it was out of place now this
is the same design but for the
alteration to the front and the the
issue of bulk and massing members were
concerned about the height there's the
same height
that issue has been looked at by an
inspector you refused it last time on
those reasons the inspector has taken
consideration of all of that and the
local circumstances
and you were not supported so if you
were to
um wish to reimpose those reasons
they've all been
ready been in rehearsed on appeal and
you've got a uh a high level decision
that disagrees with you that the
appellant would cease upon
he would say i've already been to appeal
once on this issue and
it's been been dealt with so i would i
would advise members not to
to look at the scale and the bulk of the
impacts it's a matter of taste
and people still hold the views as to
the size of it
but if you like that's been done the the
design has only been altered in the
context of that
edition at the front um so the issues
about height and
overbearing etc uh i would say that the
inspector has has rehearsed that for you
you know the outcome on that looking at
the maneuverability
in the spaces don't jump to the turning
areas yvonne um we
approached highways in the run-up to
this committee given the the issues that
were being raised
and we asked them about the swept path
movements in really searching to see
whether there was standard movements
rather than just invented ones that we
were being looked at
and what highways fed back was that they
were happy with this layout that's
before
you tonight because even though you can
draw it different ways and you can and
different drivers will behave
differently what they said by having the
larger spaces the two three and four
spaces identified there
that actually gives more maneuvering
room yes if
if a suv is perhaps parked in there that
may be constrained from time to time
but they said the bigger spaces that we
prefer
improves the maneuverability
so highways wouldn't support you if you
if you came to the view that you felt
that those spaces are inoperable
um but that's that's their view to say
the decision is for members
i think chairman i've covered what was
asked i think uh
could you just mention a disabled space
and visitor space
there's no visitor space in this scheme
or disabled
the larger schemes members will see that
they often
feature disabled spaces but normally on
the smaller domestic ones we don't
seek them the county highway authority
has often said that
on again a small scale scheme on street
parking
is acceptable we saw with the earlier
scheme tonight a similar
scheme for four flats that the inspector
in that appeal felt that the need for
the one extra speed space there'd be two
parking spaces here required for a
scheme of five um
that they can be found elsewhere now
we're not that far from
the town centre bus routes and services
the location near to alternative
transport
normally allows for a relaxation of that
now in the outlying consent that was
considered and the condition was put on
the outline that five spaces were
required this is details pursuant to
that outline so the applicant is
delivering the five spaces required of
that consent
thank you if you wouldn't mind on
sharing the screen again
please
so members i i must stress to you again
we have a very recent inspectorate
appeal
where issues have been examined as mr
strangs
has just outlined we have a clear view
from essex highways
um two members that have already spoken
uh have indicated again i'll let you
come back
once more councillor stanley
thank you chairman um i take
heed of what what
mr strength has said however
there is still i can't see a disabled
person
coming all the way down from the
the road at the rear uh
to get to the property as they're
disabled and they
would rather i mean it would be better
for them to have a carriage
than than well they wouldn't be able to
walk so they won't be able to visit
and and i thought that the idea of the
council was to uphold this
uh disabled uh space
as as high as they possibly could in
their recommendations for parking
however the disabled don't seem to get
in anywhere
they can't park in the car park up at
the town and they can't walk so the
disabled bay
is is really a relevant info relevant to
the to the site
there are five flats two bedroom flats
you know i mean how big has one site got
to be we've already
said if i remember that with that we've
allowed 37 occupational occupation
uh premises where it should be 30 per
hectare
so you know i mean if
it doesn't bear belief that we are not
we are not holding that
as high as we possibly can for the
invalids
however having said that i still contest
that it is overbearing although
it has been said that uh this has been
okay
by the inspectorate um he's not the one
that's living here
so hey there we go thank you thank you
councillor fd thank you chairman
i i was quite specific when i asked
my question about the maneuverability i
didn't ask about the space sizes i
didn't ask about
car sizes i asked about why is that
number five parking space move on the
diagram between
one diagram and the others and if they
have to move it to actually make it work
that's not going to work in real life
is this a mistake that is on the diagram
is this
something that highways needs to look at
again because
did they not notice it moved i'd like an
answer on that please thank you
just want to deal with that mr strangs
yes sorry chair um we we have asked
highways about the
idea of whether the sweatpath movement
is being presented we've
got two sets we've got those that were
submitted by the applicant we've got
another set
submitted by an objector and we asked
them to review those in the light of it
seemed that
was there any misrepresentation and
that's why
i have the answer i have colleagues have
come back and said to some extent it
doesn't matter
um there isn't a sort of a standard
movement as such but
looking at most of the movements that
are shown they would
they would work they're saying that what
is forgotten
is that the generosity of the
particularly the larger spaces
aids maneuverability and that that's the
point
so yes they may have been moved whether
it was by mistake or whatever error
but highways do not feel that makes a
difference to the overall
workability of the layout to the front
thank you
members we have a motion
for approval uh printed on
8.1 with four
points we'll take that to
the vote now can i
i think everyone is clear that they've
seen all the information
and is happy to go to that point
can i ask first of all if
any members would like a recorded vote
on this one
the threshold has been passed
so we're going to do the wrong call
i'll be asking if you uh
asking you and you'll indicate whether
you're for against
or abstaining chairman just on a point
of order i don't
recall the emotion actually being moved
or seconded
sonia would you like to cover this
please
counselor wilkinson i believe the chair
just moved it um
from the chair thank you
okay sorry that's not the words i heard
but i'll take your word for it
um counselor butcher
sorry did you not get that no
sorry um four thank you chairman
thank you councillor fd to approve
count to approve chairman thank you
thank you councillor eves
abstain thank you councillor hawkway
against
thank you councillor mr shaw four
myself for councillor stanley
against thank you councillor weston
chairman thank you councillor williams
thank you chairman that's four thank you
thank you councillor wilson
abstain chairman thank you
just uh with us one moment please
i've counted um
that is two abstentions
three against eight four that
item is approved thank you
we now will now move on to
item 9 59 la burnham way
chairman before you start with your
permission i'm going to leave the
meeting that's okay thank you
thank you um
okay mr strangs is going to take us
through
this one once more
or once when you're ready please thank
you chairman
hopefully you can hear me yes
yeah sorry chairman i've got some poor
network at the moment
um this application's the site of a
detached house on the western side
of la burnham way that you can see edged
in red on the plan before you
it's a small development of about 20
year old housing that are all detached
if we can see the photos if that's
possible if on if it's not particularly
photo photo three
um this apple is an application for a
rear door
with some roof lights what i'm hoping to
show you is that the one that's two
gardens over there
this is the bottom of the fence of the
application site
and there is a property behind that and
then the one beyond which i think is 56
luburnum
has a large flat roof dormer okay
now if we can see the elevations please
two plan
loft conversion um with three front roof
lights
uh in the existing roof the ridgeline is
not raised or altered it's all within
the envelope
of the or the carcass if you like of the
of the roof shape
um yeah if we can look at the if where
your cursor is if
it must be yours to the just left this
is the
uh proposed rear elevation and members
will see how just
how dominant this dormer is um
it maxes out the potential in the roof
um but i have a problem chairman that
this
actual dormer doesn't require planning
permission
this is an example of permitted
development
um it could actually if the roof was
bigger it could be even bigger and we
saw an example just now
of where that's already been done i
believe the applicant
in the interest of openness wishes the
council to to give a decision
and the council is duty-bound to
consider any planning application it
receives
the problem is if it doesn't require
plan admission in the first place you
can't you can't refuse it
so this has a volume of some 43 cubic
meters
and the government allows you to build
up to 50 cubic meters volume and that's
the
of the roof it doesn't include the room
that's already
under the existing loft as it were it's
only the physical edition outside the
roof
so we'd normally prefer something of a
better design
more subservient to to the the
roof scape it does have in its favor
that the axis of the windows is all
trued up
but in another place chairman it's
permitted development it doesn't require
permission
i have to advise you that you have no
choice other than to
approve it because it would be
ultraviolet to refuse it even though we
have the duty
to determine it the fact that it's
permitted development means that we
can't
um do otherwise so the recommendation
chairman is therefore approval subject
to the conditions set out in the report
thank you
thank you members um you you obviously
can't be directed to um
to to vote in any particular way
but as you've heard this is permitted
development this is allowed but
nevertheless
it is in front of us to determine
councillor stanley
i suppose i should have said that uh the
the
this um application is in my world so
yes i mentioned that i'm sorry uh my
apologies um
yes i i do feel that this is um
not a planning issue but
building requirements uh under that
requisition of uh under permitted bill
permitted building rights um and
because of uh there are presidents
already made
in in the area that we're talking about
and there's more than one that's being
done
which you haven't got photographs of i
see no reason why this applicant
can't be uh can't be put forward and
approved
thank you okay thank you um
members to save time i think if you
don't mind
if we go straight to the recommendation
for
approval which is printed on
page 9.1 3
individual points
um i think everyone is fully aware of
what they're voting on
can i ask if anyone requires a recorded
vote on this
thank you no one has indicated so
that'll be
on an electronic show of hands so at the
moment
all the hands are down so that's good so
can i
can i can i ask you hold on can i ask
you first of all to raise your hand
if you are in favor of this
application
thank you hands down
if you are against the application
please raise your hand
thank you no one has indicated
um if you are abstaining
thank you thank you that accounts for
all the members
can i just confirm did i need to state
those numbers sonia
chairman they will be recorded in the
minutes um
but the numbers um are 11 um eleven
two that item is approved then
um item ten is items referred
there are none this time round so um i
will say thank you very much for your
attendance tonight
meeting closed at 9 24. thank you
thank you chairman thank you thank you
thank you thank you chairman